أجنبي
سجل ركلة الجزاء ، لم نر
أي شيء كنا مثل أي شيء يريد
القيام به ، فلنفعل ذلك آه في الواقع كان
شيئًا جديدًا بالنسبة لنا لم نكن نعرف ما
كان يحدث هناك ولكن كان من
الجيد حقًا أننا اعتقدنا أنه كان
متواضع جدًا ولكن أيضًا لحظة ذات مغزى للغاية ،
مما يمنحه فرصة أن يكون
ملكًا للعالم لثانية واحدة عندما أعطى الملك
هذا الاقتراب وعامله
كملك ملك كرة القدم ، إنها
لحظة رائعة نعم كانت فريدة من نوعها هل
شعرت بالسوء عندما  لقد كان يرتدي أفضل قميص قطري
بالطبع ليس بالطبع بالطبع
أشعر بالفخر لأنني أعلم أنه شيء مهم ،
شكرًا لك على ما يرام ، إنها
الثقافة هنا ، ومن الجيد أن ميسي
في نفس الوقت هو لاعب كرة قدم
يمكنه أن يكون بمثابة رابط بين  كل
الثقافات لماذا ترتدي العاهرة
اليوم لأنه الزي الفوضوي الذي
يرفع تلغراف كأس العالم
فوكس نيوز